do you still ought ition and [ __ ] or not
yeah because I know that I think it's
stuff it's like because there's so much
content and stuff that's being made all
the time that everybody wants to get it
on now so the auditioning is back it
like I think everybody's in the room I
see a lot of people that I'm like you
audition oh [ __ ] yeah he's young like
you'd be great at auditions I'm I'm
pretty good at being in front of like
that small group of people and not being
uncomfortable when it's producers and
all that stuff but I'm not as good when
I I don't know I'm just not like self
tapes and stuff I don't feel the
pressure so I don't get a lot of
responses really no this is though now
we're onto something because the last
three self tapes something started here
top the previous two something again
Jesus this guy um but you're right it's
like the last three or four tapes I've
sent will never lean I didn't get them
or no response really yeah and I think
that you know the ones that I do go in
is it's more of a well this is what's
different about you if people he has an
aura about him that I feel like in
person you do give off a very very
different aura than when you're on a
tape because you are a special what's an
aura mean your energy your very
eccentric your very um weird and and you
do little things that make people laugh
like when you're not doing your seat
right right people remember that they
remember how you made them feel
Danny DeVito got taxi because he had
audition for so many things in New York
City where he's told his agents and
managers send me and if it says
six-foot-tall send me and send me an and
he knew he wasn't going to get the role
yeah they remembered him yeah the one
that mattered came you know that matter
taxi yeah yeah the one that matter came
it's so interesting and it's like you
know when you go in there sometimes
they're not even did sometimes they
don't want the guy that knows the scene
inside and out and it's like you know
yeah sometimes they want you know
somebody that's just like diff
well Eric Stonestreet said it best he's
like if you nail your audition then they
know that's your ceiling if you give
them something where you're where they
can use their imagination and say you
know what
you nailed this part I wonder how much
better he could be there's more of an
intrigue rather than okay that was the
best that he's a thespian he's you know
yeah yeah yeah he said something to me
once I was in an audition right and he
was shooting he was on Modern Family and
they were shooting in the area where the
door of the audition was and he saw me
walk in right and he saw me like I
looked at him he knows how nervous I get
I get really nervous and I sat in this
audition right I signed up my name your
little things like what time did you
come in and wisely why is that their
time did you get there and what time is
your dish and put the time of my
audition in the get there watching rice
I'm tired but what does it even either
just check so you sign there's like
three four columns yeah right you have
to put your rage in yeah oh that's
[ __ ] sometimes I just go get Oh
ditto right from other people and Anna
will you just read the other names
you're like oh did you see some names
are like the [ __ ] it's like I'm going in
for nimah and then you're like
everybody's names on there I was sitting
there really nervous and Eric walks into
the lobby but I think he's gonna razz me
or tease me or whatever and he comes to
my ear he whispers something you know
what he says and he walks out and I'd
had a good audition and I thought to
myself that right there is a true
[ __ ] friend me somebody like I have
some friends that would try to sabotage
it really yeah I would have a friend
Cohen there I know I'm gonna name names
I'm not going to that would walk in
there though don't [ __ ] this up it means
everything right and walk out right but
that guy Eric Stonestreet said you know
you got this it doesn't have to be
perfect and that's a gift when that's a
real friend right there man you know
well you know I I was in all the
castings on all the Lionsgate movies
that I did so I read with a lot of
people because I just wanted to see
their and see the process a lot of
people a lot of people in LA are not
prepared when they come in which is wild
yeah yeah like look terrible terrible
attitude I couldn't believe how limited
our choices were based on people that
came in that were like bright-eyed and
ready to go Wow everybody else look like
they just rolled out a hide 22 minutes
ago yeah it's like a little dippity-do
in their hair but I think somebody once
told me though that that's how you go in
you go in not wanting it right good you
go in like you're above it like you're
dressed like I'm doing something you
know like that's insulting though that's
what they told me that once I got above
all it was Eric Stonestreet on another
day yeah you're right I just probably
doesn't you know if you're like grossly
unprepared that's just an insulting but
now there's so many other factors there
are some places that want to know your
Instagram numbers when you audition
you're you know the politics about here
it's it's so very political competitive
and then the comedy world and then
everything the extension of it this is
like a this is like an obstacle course
out here man you know and it's a lottery
there's a lot of factors it's weird
because I think part of it is my number
when you did that movie with Casper and
these kids had like seven million
followers yeah and it's just security to
get their money back you know to make
sure that whoever these young kids that
follow these guys are going to buy the
movie on iTunes and they know for a fact
they're gonna get their money back after
like three YouTube star movies and it's
like it's really interesting because
number one it's not their thing to be
sets it out of mark right right and just
you know they don't know what the
cameras do or like you know and what jib
is or terminology and they're just
learning on their feet and I'm like
totally there to you know support them
but um it sucks for people young comics
now because
listen I've been on a network sitcom
maybe a third year coming and not a
single person has said to me I love you
on that show my point is not because I'm
not good on it it's a point but they're
a Stonestreet
come on in my point is that there's so
much out there right yeah there is so
much out there you have to be in a
culturally like a game of Thrones oh ham
is till something that shifts cultures
and yeah I also feel like you're such a
big not saying that you're you don't
bring value to the show you're on I'm
sure I didn't I haven't seen the show
yeah I'm sure it's a great show but and
I said this to you in the club a few
years ago we were having like one of our
just you know stark get to the point of
it I said Bobby your your vehicle is
gonna be something you make that's you
in the center you're berry on HBO there
is a [ __ ] show that I see and I'm a
visual person you doing that you still
haven't done yet I haven't if you
haven't had the opportunity maybe from
this you have been trekking right I saw
you too right yeah yeah well the next
phase of my whole shift is like I'm
writing directing producing oh you know
what Jordan Jordan is doing I love it
do you see us yeah I thought I liked it
better than get out really layers of
layers
yeah I have to see
[Music]